okay so it's Monday November 9 2009 in
other words three years one month and 12
days until the earth gets ripped in half
by a black hole nuclear war a meteor
strike or another form of Armageddon
that destroys all life on Earth and yes
I'm talking about December 21st 2012 the
end of the world otherwise known as
complete and utter [ __ ]
okay so for you people out there looking
for a video with scientific evidence to
debunk the whole 2012 apocalypse theory
well I just don't have that however I do
see that the world was supposed to have
ended about seven times since the 80s
and we are a people who tend to see the
Virgin Mary's face in a burnt toaster
pastry so take those two inconvenient
truths and mix them both together and
you have a formula to see that we're
probably once again just overreacting
and seeing [ __ ] that's just not there
and to that phrase every married guy out
there just thought to himself yeah I
know what that's like okay so as some of
you may or may not know there is a
belief that on December 21st 2012 the
world will end
due to that being the date that the
Mayan calendar ends saying that this
means the end of the world is like
saying when the odometer in your car
reaches all nines and on the next mile
is going to revert the count back to
zero instead of cycling the counter
round back to zero your car is going to
explode yeah it's kind of a leap but
let's face it we've had a long sad
history of wanting to believe that the
world is ending June 6 2006 the world
was ending y2k New Year's 2000 the world
was ending I remember the y2k scare
people actually believed that we were
gonna live all like Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome and [ __ ] after the new years
of 2000 we cleaned out grocery stores
and gun shops to fortify our homes and
wait for the apocalypse to come on
January 1st 2000 well this was not the
zombie dream we all knew and loved
this [ __ ] got real people expected to
wake up to shotgun blasts and molotov
cocktails like it was left for dead or
something but in the end they woke up
like this
what time is it
snow apocalypse just a hangover and an
entire garage packed with non-perishable
canned food and space blankets and rest
assured this time in 2012 history will
repeat itself we're going to be so
worked up over this we're going to
expect to wake up to the blood-soaked
moon and fire and brimstone like us
today a la voz or some [ __ ] but in
reality we're probably going to wake up
like this because of like Christmas
presents now damn it
the world is not going to end in 2012
even the modern-day Mayans say that the
end of the world notion is [ __ ] and
yes there are still minds in the world
Mayan archaeologist Jose hukum says and
this is a quote if I went to some mind
speaking communities and asked people
what was going to happen in 2012 they
wouldn't have any idea we have real
concerns these days like rain the
authors of what we've taken is the end
of the world prophecy say that the 2012
end of the world theory is [ __ ] I
don't know about you but I'll take their
word over ours because something tells
me that modern-day Mayans might know a
little more about the subject rather
than some fanatic and Mississippi
screaming mother forget the kid's world
Jenin well boom die whirl Jenin we are
all gonna die the great thing about this
is this should be the final tribal
scenario pertaining to the end of the
world if this doesn't pan out
no one can ever claim to know when the
world's gonna end ever again it'll just
be like yes the star alignment strongly
suggests that the essay that the whole
Mayan Armageddon thing didn't work out
did you don't know what you're talking
about just save it I know the funny
thing is we won't let it go because when
we are still alive on December 22nd 2012
by December 23rd at the latest some
quadruple PhD guy from Harvard is gonna
come out and say well you see the Latin
term for the end of the world is
Armageddon and if you arrange key
letters in the word Armageddon correctly
and add a few missing fragments you will
then clearly see that it spills the
title of Tupac's album loyal to the game
and loyal sounds like royal and a royal
deck has 52 cards in it which of course
clearly means 52 years past said
Armageddon 2012
so technically speaking the world will
end in 2064 but don't worry it will
happen we promise and it will then as
now be a load of [ __ ] now I imagine
there are people who are going to watch
this and completely disagree with me and
think that the world is indeed doomed in
three years and I'm an ignorant dick to
say otherwise and who is right only time
will tell
but if I am indeed wrong and the world
does end in 2012 well I would formally
apologize right here but we're all going
to be dead
so as Linkin Park once said in the end
doesn't even matter
just please don't blindly follow the
sci-fi channel specials and news
tabloids that scream the end is nigh the
sake of getting you all worked up just
to sell more deep batteries and Bunsen
burners instead concern yourself with
more worthwhile endeavors in life like
how do we get the show Firefly back on
the air so what do you believe is going
to happen on December 21st 2012 comment
me message me I want to know what you
think and stay tuned for my review of
the 2012 movie where we take a good look
at the one thing that's more ridiculous
than the world tarring in half in three
years and that is that roland emmerich
is still allowed to make movies